okay this is a this is actually an
interesting one
so
this is a clip
where he's talking to a bunch of
thoughts
let me just uh
hang on pause this because it's because
it's talking about how men have all the
power and the patriarchy and oppression
all that sort of stuff and this is one
of the ones that really pisses people
off and by the way if you're watching
this still on my old channel at
entrepreneurs and cars the unplugged
alpha podcast is on its own channel i've
dropped the link in the description i've
dropped it in live chat i'm going to
kill the feed on the entrepreneurs and
cars channel right now so head over to
tua the unplugged alpha on youtube and
subscribe there
and that's killed
done
all right because i still get like dms
and emails from people going like where
do i find your podcast i can't find any
more on the channel i don't know it's
like okay well i'll keep doing this
until i stop getting those emails maybe
the dms and then it'll sync in but it is
what it is right so let's throw this one
up so this one is the
chrome tab
uh equality and equal rights one so
let's throw this up here
and let's get some volume if you guys
can't hear this let me know in the chat
but i'm turning it right up so you
should be okay
power
is women
hang on license plate you can confuse
this very often they talk about the fact
that men have all the power men make all
the money men are in charge and we
oppress women
let me make something very clear to you
firstly you're confusing one percent of
men with all men the majority of men
have no money no power no sex from their
wife no [ __ ] chance in court you
can't even keep their house they won't
get to see their kids and they don't so
most men their life sucks
so it's not wrong like this is
the reality for most guys today in you
know western countries they're
their life generally does suck and what
he's describing is 100 sure but just
listen to what he's diving into here
that's the first thing the second thing
when a man gets up at four in the
morning to go carry garbage to earn a
good wage he ain't thinking i'm gonna do
this so i could oppress that [ __ ]
because she's broke he's doing it
thinking so i can provide for my family
so my woman can stay at home and raise
my kids and have nice nails while i'm
out here carrying trash you go to a coal
mine those dudes are not down there
thinking about oppressing women they're
down they're thinking about providing
for women now i'm not saying so
you know there's a lot of arguments that
from the
wokish you know sort of crowd where
they're all like oh you know men are
making for every dollar a man earns a
woman makes like 75 cents or whatever
and it's like every single entrepreneur
that you talk to be like if that was the
case then i would only hire women so
it's truthfully not the case because
their hiring practices don't reflect
that narrative that women get paid less
than uh men they just don't i mean
the argument is moot because what ends
up happening is women end up choosing
jobs that generally pay less because
they either work less hours or they
don't require
um the same level of risk like you know
a guy working in a coal mine is more
risky than working in a uh
in a children's nursery you know for
example like the worst that's gonna
happen is you're gonna have to change a
shitty diaper a kid throws up on the
floor right that's the worst where's the
coal mind the whole thing can [ __ ]
collapse on your head you can die or
you're going to end up with
some respiratory you know disease and
die at like 45 years old or something
like that you see what i'm saying right
so
what he's saying is like factually and
true about the reality of what most men
take on they're not trying to oppress
women they're actually trying to provide
for their families but you know there's
this new narrative where it's like you
know women think that serving a man at
home is oppressive
so they'll go and get a degree put it on
a wall frame it mahogany with little
letters after their name and then go and
work for a man and serve him instead
right it's like
where's the logic in that right it just
doesn't make a lot of sense but
anyway we'll finish this off
saying that there's not bad apples but
in general us men are prepared to take
on more [ __ ] to protect you than you
would possibly believe and in the modern
world they've spun that
feminism spun that men make all the man
money you women need more money because
men make the money and men are in charge
and men have the good jobs men are out
here giving up their [ __ ] life for
you chicks those women confuse this very
often
so there's that one
it's like you know
i mean the thing is that people men
especially think that by
making sacrifices for women
um
that they're going to be appreciated and
the reality of the world is is that men
are never appreciated and loved in the
way that they want to be appreciated
loved by women there's there's a whole
disney narrative that you know a lot of
kids grew up on especially in my you
know generation era where it's like they
got federals [ __ ] with disney and
castles and princesses and you know you
swoop into your rescuer and she's gonna
love you forever until kingdom come but
that's just that
like segment of the movie they don't
actually show what living together and
being married and having kids and then
inviting the state in your household and
family law and all those things can
potentially do to that relationship over
long-term basis after the dude's been
better ties through a thousand
concessions and now you know loses frame
and all these sorts of things that you
know starts to happen um there's no
appreciation for the sacrifices that men
make they'll never appreciate the
sacrifices that men make and don't
expect them to they just can't possibly
see it because of solipsism they just
don't see past their noses and that's
why we live in a world today where a guy
like andrew tate you know can sit around
with all these thoughts and make these
statements and you know they might sort
of nod and laugh at some of this i mean
you know we heard a few of them laughing
at some of the statements that they you
know that he made but they're not going
to change the lens in which they view
the world they're still going to go home
after you know sitting beside him and
you know presenting their arguments
during the show or whatever and still
think themselves well i'm oppressed you
know
i don't get paid enough uh you know the
patriarchy blah blah blah sort of stuff
all these things are pretty common you
know like narratives right like it is
what it is all right so let's pull this
one out and uh stop screen
making pretty good time here
let's do the other one here so this is
um okay so this one gets into again the
differences between men and women right
this is a very very short 21 second clip
and he's using uh the differences with
promiscuity as a very good example with
this one uh so let's grab that
powerful men so the difference between
powerful men and powerful women
all right let's play that and volume up
boom if i walk through a club and i [ __ ]
every girl in the club i'm a powerful
man right if a woman walks into the club
and every man wants her and not a single
man can touch her she's a powerful woman
if you flip the reverse if i'm a man i
walk in and i can't [ __ ] anything i
don't matter and if the girl walks in
and every dude in there silly right and
she won't work [ __ ] if i walk through a
club and i [ __ ] everything all right so
that's a replacement's gonna keep going
so
i mean
the stating that there's inherent
differences between the value in men and
women
for some reason offends people right
like
look men are success objects women are
beauty objects they're always going to
be viewed that way they've always been
viewed that way throughout history women
always gravitated to the highest value
guys guy or guys that they could get
and
men
would take on you know these women when
they expressed interest in them as long
as they were beauties that they were
interested in
there's never been a time in history
even to this day there's there's like
even to this day there is there's no guy
that'll be like oh yeah look at the
degree on her check out that degree as
she walks away that's hot sort of thing
they just don't right guys don't do that
they're
they're looking at her other assets if
you will you see what i'm saying right
so
you know when it comes to the whole
conversation around you know promiscuity
um guys are generally disgusted by
promiscuous women whereas women are not
generally disgusted by promiscuous men
they may not like it they may not be
ideal for long-term mate selections if
they want to raise a family
you know because parental investment is
something that they're going to be
concerned with right like they want the
guy to stick around to help raise a kid
and provide resources because that's
what family law steps in and takes care
of right now for
um you know women the way that's been
written but
um
like it's a fact of life like where's
the lie again you know is anybody in the
comments there telling me that there's a
lie that we're dealing with here because
i'm not seeing it yet so you know you
guys let me know hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you